y otros valores llevan años observando
impotentes como los pasillos y Este
mercado están cada vez más vacíos y Con
razón hace cinco años para luchar contra
la contaminación textil Ruanda adoptó la
política Marín Ruanda que consiste en
grabar excesivamente las prendas de
segunda mano que llegan al país las
cosas están difíciles Estos días los
clientes vienen y piensan que pueden
conseguir artículos a precios bajos como
antes pero descubren que nuestros
precios son muy altos porque nosotros
también compramos a precios muy altos ya
casi no obtenemos beneficios por ejemplo
esta camiseta que el año pasado costaba
2,5 dólares hoy cuesta 6 dólares
mientras que los clientes han abandonado
la tienda de bobo en la capital cada vez
más son los que compran sus textil para
hacer vestimenta personalizada
comodistas como arroz
[Música]
aquí reciba ruandeses pero también a
extranjeros hago sus diseños a medida
con wax pero también con ropa
tradicional Made In Ruanda es bueno para
mí porque puedo pagar los gastos
escolares de mis hijos
volver a la ropa hecha a medida
corresponde también a una necesidad de
reconectar con las tradiciones del país
son estos diseños tradicionales llamados
imigongo los que hacen que el Made In
Ruanda sea tan famoso el imigongo que se
utilizaba para decorar el Palacio real
50 ahora en las creaciones de los
mayores marcas de lujo del país como
motion aquí cada creación cuenta una
parte de la cultura ruandesa
nuestra tienda está en una perspectiva
sostenible en la que no solo queremos
producir sino también educar a los
clientes sobre la procedencia de los
tejidos pero también sobre el
significado cultural de los diseños
con diseñadores que sitúan la ecología
en el centro la moda media en Ruanda
atrae la atención internacional hace
menos de un año motions apareció en la
famosa revista blog